>>> HAPPY WEEK 13, EVERYBODY.
YOU TAPPED INTO THE ALL-BETTING
SQUAD LIVE IN THE BLEACHER
REPORT APP PRESENTED BY DRAFT
KINGS.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS ALONGSIDE THE
GIVING SPIRIT OVER HERE IN CRAIG
IVORY.
HOW ARE WE FEELING, MAN IN THE
SEASON IS FLYING BY NOW.
>> THE SEASON IS FLYING BY,
CONNOR.
I MEAN, WE'RE IN THE CHRISTMAS
SPIRIT HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS HOODIES.
AND, ACTUALLY, CONNOR, I'M IN
THE COMMENTS NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
TAKES AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
LOOKING FOR WINNERS.
I'M LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I SEE THE LEAGUE MVP.
LEAGUE MVP SAID ANTONIO GIBSON.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
FIRST HOODIE.
>> I LIKE WASHINGTON, TOO.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT LATER ON.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL BY NOW.
IT'S THE SHOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
WHO IS GETTING IN THE END ZONE.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL AND IN
THE APP EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND THESE
ARE THE TOP SELECTIONS FROM THIS
WEEK.
LEONARD FOURNETTE COMING OFF A
MONSTER WEEK.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
PUTTING THE FANTASY COMMUNITY
AWELL WHAT HIM AND MIXON CAN DO
ON THE GROUND.
MIKE EVANS HAS BEEN A BEAST
SINCE HE GOT IN THE LEAGUE.
NOW WITH TOM BRADY HE'S
LIMITLESS.
JUSTIN R
JUSTIN JEFFERSON, YOU'RE EYEING
THAT ONE.
A JUICY MATCHUP FOR HIM.
CHASE IS THE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
SORRY MAC JONES, LOVERS.
HUNTER RENFROW AND KEENAN ALLEN
PLUS-MONEY CHOICES GETTING IN ON
THE ACTION.
GOING TO BE A FUN ONE TODAY.
SO THAT BEING SAID, I KNOW YOU
GOT THE HOODIES, GREG.
WE DO THAT EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
YOU GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
YOUR POCKET.
TELL US WHAT YOU'RE GIVING AWAY.
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING OUT
HOODIES, CONNOR, I'M GIVING AWAY
TWO NFL JERSEYS.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LEGEND
AND ONE GOES TO A LUCKY
COMMENTER LIKE YOURSELF.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DO WHAT
YOU DO, IF YOU WANT A JERSEY.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE I NEED
EMOJIS AND GIFs.
YOU KNOW WHAT I NEED.
I NEED WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
TYPE IT OUT.
I'M LOOKING FOR YOU GUYS IN THE
COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
LET'S GO, CONNOR.
>> FORAGE DARE PICKS TO SHOW
YOU.
YOU CAN THROW A LITTLE BIT OF
MONEY ON THAT.
MIGHT NOT AT THIS POINT.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
THE FIST ONE IS FROM -- TELL US
WHO IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY.
>> FARING ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
THIS WEEK.
>> KEENAN ALLEN.
>> THE CHIP SHOT LEGEND ONE TAKE
ONLY GOING WITH KEENAN ALLEN.
PLUS 150.
HE GOT IN THE END ZONE TWICE
THIS YEAR.
THAT MEANS HE'S THERE, GREG.
SECOND ONE IS FROM JOHN JOHN
TAKING ON THE CHIP SHOT LEGEND.
IF.
>> JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
IF IT'S SIX, WE PICK.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON PLUS MONEY.
LOVE SEEING ONE OF THE TOP
SCORING RECEIVERS IN THE LEAGUE
AT THAT PLUS MONEY MARK AGAINST
KEENAN ALLEN.
PLUS 150.
GOLF LEGEND CANDY COMPANY IN THE
CHRISTMAS SPIRIT LEGEND.
GREG, WE'LL NEED A LITTLE HELP
FROM THIS ONE.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED
FROM MATCH UP NUMBER ONE.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW WHICH WAY WE SHOULD RIDE.
SHOULD WE GO WITH THE GOLF
LEGEND IN KEENAN ALLEN OR JUSTIN
JEFFERSON?
CONNOR, I'LL HOP IN HERE.
KEENAN ALLEN PLAY?
I DO SEE THE CHARGERS BOUNCING
BACK THIS WEEK AFTER A TOUGH ONE
LAST WEEK.
I SEE A BIG GAME FROM JUSTIN.
ASEE A BIG GAME FROM HIM.
I KIND OF LIKE THE KEENAN ALLEN
PLAY.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON PLAY.
LOOK FOR HIM TO GET ON TRACK.
HE'S FACING THE LIONS DEFENSE
WHO WAS GREAT.
29th IN PASSING YARDS PER GAME.
HE HAD A QUIET GAME AGAINST THE
NINERS.
BUT I LOOK FOR HIM TO BOUNCE
BACK AGAINST THIS DETROIT
DEFENSE, CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> YEAH.
I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
LIKE WE SAID EARLIER KEENAN
ALLEN HARD TO EXPECT HIM TO
SCORE ON A WEEKLY BASIS NOW.
MORE IMPORTANTLY A LOT GOING IN
THE WAY FOR THE WAY OF JUSTIN
JEFFERSON.
THE MATCH UP.
LOVE IT AGAINST THE LIONS.
ALL FOR IT, GREG.
THERE'S NOT A CRAZY DROPOFF WHEN
DALVIN COOK GETS HURT TO MADISON
IN TERMS OF WORKLOAD AND
PRODUCTION.
THEY RUN THE OFFENSE THE SAME.
THEY LOOK TO GET MADISON 20 TO
25 TOUCHES.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB.
I THINK WHEN YOU GET IN THE RED
ZONE, YOU HAVE TO GET JEFFERSON
INVOLVED.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND SAY IT, GREG,
WE'LL SEE IF THE COMMENTS AGREE
IN A SECOND.
I THINK JUSTIN JEFFERSON IS A
LOCK THIS WEEK TO GET IN THE END
ZONE.
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
I LOVE THOSE VIBES, CONNOR.
I LOVE THE VIBES.
LET MOE SEE IF THEY'RE VIBING
WITH US IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I LOVE CABBY.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON ALL THE WAY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I GOT WD 13 SAYS JUSTIN
JEFFERSON ONE MORE.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
CONNOR?
I FEEL LIKE IT'S APPARENT.
>> IT'S A WRAP.
>> JUSTIN JEFFERSON IN THE PLUS
MONEY PLUS 110 IS MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT ROUND.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ROUND ONE IN THE BOOKS.
THE CANDY COMPANY LEGEND GOING
WITH JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
STILL GOT TWO CHALLENGERS ON THE
BOARD.
THE NEXT ONE IS A VERY FAMILIAR
FACE IN W TRAMPLE.
WE KNOW THE KIND OF DAMAGE HE
DOES WEEK IN AND WEEK OUT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE IS COOKING
TH
THIS WEEK.
ALL RIGHT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO ASK HOW
TRAMPLE COCKED OFF THE LOB
INSIDE THE CLAW MACHINE AND I
WON'T ASK HOW MANY QUARTERS IT
COST EITHER.
MIKE EVANS MINUS 105.
HE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE LOCKS TO
SCORE AS A WIDE RECEIVER THIS
YEAR, GREG.
YOU KNOW WE LIKE THAT PLUS
MONEY.
WE ALSO KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO
WITH IT.
THIS IS A JUICY MATCH UP HERE IN
ROUND TWO.
>> I LOVE WHAT YOU SAID, CONNOR.
WE KNOW WHAT WE DO ON THE SQUAD.
WE ODD THE THINGS UP.
BEFORE WE ODD THOSE ANYTHING UP,
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET ME KNOW.
SHOULD WE WRIED MIKE EVANS IN
THE CLAW LEGEND OR STICK WITH
JUSTIN JEFFERSON IN THE CANDY
CANE LEGEND.
HONESTLY, CONNOR, I'LL BE
HONEST.
I'M TORN HERE.
>> YOU CAN'T GO WRONG.
>> ABSOLUTELY TORN.
YOU CAN'T GO WRONG HERE.
I MEAN, BEFORE LAST WEEK, MIKE
EVANS SCORED FOUR CONSECUTIVE
WEEKS.
HE SCORED A TOUCHDOWN IN FOUR
CONSECUTIVE WEEKS.
I SEE HIM BOUNCING BACK AGAINST
THAT ATLANTA DEFENSE.
I'M ABSOLUTELY TORN.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU?
>> I THINK WITH MIKE EVANS,
BASICALLY SINCE ANTONIO BROWN
GOT HURT AND NOW HE DEALS WITH
THE SUSPENSION WHILE REHABBING
THE INJURY, THAT'S WHERE THEY
LOOK TO OUT OF THEIR WIDE
RECEIVERS.
WE KNOW HOW GOOD CHRIS GOODWIN
IS AND WHEN GRONK IS ON THE
FIELD HE'S A FAVORITE OF BRADY'S
AND WHAT LESS THANNY CAN DO ON
THE GROUND.
MIKE EVANS IS MR. CONSISTENT.
JEFFERSON IS AN ABSOLUTE SUPER
STAR I'M GOOD EITHER WAY ON
THESE, GREG.
I'LL LET THE PEOPLE.
USUALLY WE SWAY THEM.
WE PROBABLY WILL TRY TO SWAY YOU
FOR THE FINAL ROUND.
ROUND TWO GOES TO THE PEOPLE.
>> IT'S STRAIGHT TO THE PEOPLE.
>> ONE SAID MIKE EVANS.
HE GAVE US THE MIKE EVANS GIF.
THERE IT IS.
BOBBING AND WEAVING AND THROWING
AN UPPER CUT.
I HAVE JULIAN.
HE SAID EVANS IS A LOT AGAINST
THE FALCONS DEFENSE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I HAVE ONE MORE IN ME.
ACTUALLY -- ACTUALLY, THEY'RE
BACK AND FORTH, CONNOR.
I HAVE TO CALL IT HOW I SEE IT.
I SEE JG QUINN 26 JEFFERSON IS
GOING TO LIGHT UP THE LION'S
SECONDARY.
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
I LOVE THAT TAKE.
I'M GOING TO WALK IT OFF WITH
THIS ONE.
HE SAID EVAN IS A LOCK.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, CORNER,
THAT BEING SAID, MIKE EVANS THE
CLAW LEGEND AND MY GUY TRAMPLE
IS MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> ALWAYS COMING AND DISRUPTING
AND KNOCKING PEOPLE OFF.
FINAL ROUND WE GOT MIKE EVANS ON
THE BOARD.
WE GOT THE OLD-TIMER TRAMPLE.
BUT NOW WE GOT ANOTHER PICK FROM
PRO ANGLER JB.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE'S GOT OUT
THERE FISHING.
>> WHAT'S UP.
I'M OUT HERE ON THE WATER TODAY.
YOU HAVE TO SEE WHAT I PULLED
IN.
LEONARD FOURNETTE ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE MINUS 165.
>> ELEVENY LOOKING LIKE REGULAR
SEASON LESNNY.
MINUS 16 A.
I THINK YOU, GREG, CAN GET THAT
TO A NICE PLACE WHERE WE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT IT.
MIKE EVANS MINUS 105.
WE HAVE TEAMMATES IN THE FINAL
ROUND.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF WHAT TEAM.
IT'S A MATTER OF WHO IS SCORING
ON THE BUCS AND, BOY, THEY SCORE
A LOT OF POINTS.
FINAL ROUND HOW ARE WE FEELING
ABOUT THIS ONE?
WHERE ARE WE GOING WITH IT?
>> CONNOR, LET ME SAY, WOO SA.
THIS IS TOUGH.
IT'S TOUGH.
SO WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND GIVE ME
REPS AND TELL ME WHO WE SHOULD
BE RIDING WITH.
BECAUSE I'M TORN ONCE AGAIN,
CORNER.
I'M TORN ONCE AGAIN.
WE TALKED ABOUT MIKE EVANS
ALREADY.
CAN WE TALK ABOUT LEONARD
FOURNETTE AND WHAT HE'S DONE,
LIKE, HE'S BEEN ABSOLUTELY
FALLING FOR TOUCHDOWNS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
COME ON.
SITTING AT MINUS 165.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO HERE.
I'M TORN, CONNOR.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY TO GO.
I'M GOING WITH THE WAY OF THE
PEOPLE LEAD ME.
BUT WHICH WAY ARE YOU RIDING,
CONNOR?
WHICH WAY DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
GO?
>> KNOWING WHERE WE CAN GET THAT
FOURNETTE LINE, GREG.
TO AT LEAST EVEN.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
NO SPOILERS HERE.
I GOT TO DEFER THE RUNNING BACK.
AS GREAT AS EVANS WILL BE AND AS
GREAT AS THE PASSING OFFENSE IS.
I MEAN, GREG SCORED FOUR
TOUCHDOWNS.
WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE.
ONE.
I'M GOING LEONARD FOURNETTE.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING
TAKE US FOR THE SQUAD ROD LEADER
OF WEEK 13?
>> MY BOY JUSTIN BOGFIELD SAID
LOOK AT THE MOVE.
LENNY ALL DAY AND HE'S HOT.
HE GAVE ME A GIFT.
I'LL SHOW YOU GUYS THE GIF.
>> LSU.
>> THERE IT IS.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I AMBAC INTO THE COMMENTS.
I GOT ELI.
ELI GAVE ME THE GIF.
ALL WILL JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
I HAVE BRANDON DEGRASSE.
AND SYDNEY SAID MINUS 16 A.
EVERYBODY I MENTIONED YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
CONNOR, IT APPEARS WE CAME TO A
DECISION.
THE FISHING LEGEND.
THE FISHING LEGEND PRO ANGLER
J.B.
LEONARD FOURNETTE IS THE WINNER
OF TODAY'S SQUAD RIDE.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC SO I
CAN SHOW YOU AND SO I CAN SHOW
SYDNEY AND EVERYBODY WHAT WE AND
ALL OF US DO.
YOU SEE LEONARD FOURNETTE MINUS
165.
OH.
THERE'S THE MAGIC.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS.
WE'RE GOING TO BOOST THAT UP
FROM MINUS 165 TO PLUS 110.
CHECK IT OUT.
LET'S GET RICH THIS SUNDAY.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONNOR, WE
WANT WINNERS AND WE WANT WINNERS
ONLY LEAGUES.
>> PLUS 110, GREG.
THAT IS -- AH.
THAT'S SOME OF YOUR BEST WORK
YET ON THE SHOW.
I THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
HAPPY WITH THAT.
LEONARD FOURNETTE PLUS 110.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO.
GET ON DRAFT KINGS AND HAVE FUN
WITH THAT.
THE COMMUNITY COMMENT CONTEST
TIME.
SHOWOUT TO PRO ANGLER JB.
YOU GET THE JERSEY AND THE SQUAD
LEADER TITLE.
WELL DONE.
WE ASK YOU WHO ARE YOU BETTING
ON TO MAKE OR MISS THE PLAYOFFS
IN THE BOARD IS PRETTY EVEN NOW.
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN A LOT OF
RUNWAYS THIS YEAR CONSIDERING
HOW FAR INTO THE SEASON WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
SO, GREG, WHAT DID YOU GET?
WHAT CAME YOUR WAY THIS WEEK?
I KNOW THIS IS WHEN THINGS GET
CRAZY.
PEOPLE START THROWING OUT THE
TAKES.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT WE GOT.
>> A LOT CAME IN.
A LOT CAME IN.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED, CONNOR.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WITH THE
CONTEST, I HAVE TO GIVE MY GUY
JAKE -- I'M SORRY.
JAKE A SHOT OUT BECAUSE HE'S
KEEPING IT REAL.
>> TOO REAL.
>> NO BETS ARE SAFE.
HE SAID IT.
WE FEEL YOUR PAIN, BROTHER.
FOR THAT, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
IT'S THE SEASON THE GIVING.
NOW I NEED EVERYBODY THAT IS
HERE RIGHT NOW TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH OF
THESE IS A BETTER TAKE.
I'M GIVING A HOODIE TO WHOEVER
YOU GUYS CHOOSE.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FIRST COMMENT FROM H GREEN 89.
THEY SAID LIKE VIKINGS AND
COLTS.
THEY BOTH RUN THE BALL EVEN
WITHOUT DALVIN.
THAT'S HUGE DOWN THE STRETCH.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS,
CONNOR?
>> I LIKE THE THOUGHT PROCESS.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR TEAMS THAT
CAN CONTROL THE CLOCK.
THAT CAN RELY ON THEIR RUN GAME
WHEN THEIR QUARTERBACKS AREN'T
CLICKING.
I THINK BOTH OF THE TEAMS ARE IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY NEED THAT.
YOU HAVE TO HELP WIN WENTZ AND
COUSINS.
THEY'RE OKAY.
BUT THEY'RE NOT SUPER STARS BY
ANY STRETCH.
ABOUT DALVIN COOK THAT'S A
SCHEME-PROOF RUN OFFENSE WHERE
MADISON COMES IN AND GETS THE
JOB DONE RIGHT AWAY.
NOW THEY'RE IN A PRETTY BRUTAL
DIVISION WHICH YOU'RE TEARING UP
AT THE PACKERS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T MAKE
THE PLAYOFFS.
I COLTS NOW I DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THEIR DIVISION AT ALL OR THEIR
SCHEDULE AT ALL.
I CAME AWAY WITH THEIR LOSS
AGAINST THE BUCS LIKE THEY'RE
FOR REAL.
THEY CAN HANG WITH THE BIG DOGS,
AT LEAST.
I LIKE THIS TAKE A LOT.
I THINK IT'S ON THE MONEY.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
I LIKE IT, TOO.
WE KNOW WHAT THE COLTS CAN DO
WITH THE RUN GAME.
AND LIKE YOU SAID, EVEN WITHOUT
DALVIN COOK, THE VIKINGS ARE
ABLE TO SHOW THEY CAN RUN THE
FOOTBALL.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
COMMENT, CONNOR.
MOVING ON.
HUH 424020.
HE SENT THIS AGAIN.
HE SENT A GIF.
A BILL BELICHICK PATRIOTS GIF.
THE PATRIOTS ARE MAKING IT IN.
I THINK THEY ARE.
I LIKE MAC JONES.
HE'S DOING IT IN HIS ROOKIE
SEASON.
I THINK HE'LL PAN OUT TO BE A
GOOD PICK FOR THE PATRIOTS.
I SEE THEM MAKING IT TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
THEY CAN RUN THE BALL, THEY PLAY
SOLID DEFENSE, THEY HAVE A GAME
MANAGER IN MAC JONES.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE, CONNOR?
>> YEAH.
ALL OVER IT.
THEY WIN IN THE TRENCHES.
IT'S NOT JUST THE OFFENSIVE LINE
BUT THEIR DEFENSIVE LINE, THEY
GET IT DONE IN THE TRENCHES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL.
THE ROOKIE QUARTERBACK IS
EXTREMELY EFFICIENT, AS YOU
SAID.
WE KNOW HOW WELL COACHED OF A
TEAM THEY ARE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER AT THE END OF
THE DAY HOW THEY SPLIT AGAINST
THE BILLS OR LOOK AGAINST THE
BILLS.
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM IN THE
PLAYOFFS FOR TWO TEAMS.
THE BIGGER THING THAT THE
DOLPHINS HAVE BEEN A COMPLETE
DUD IN THAT DIVISION.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A
THREE-TEAM RACE.
@HASN'T BEEN THE CASE.
NEW ENGLAND HAS BEEN RIGHT IN
THE THICK OF THINGS.
THEY LOOK BETTER THAN MIAMI.
WE'LL FIND OUT A LOT AGAINST THE
BILLS.
I LIKE IT.
USUALLY OUR COMMENTS ARE TOO OFF
THE WALL FOR ME.
I LIKE ALL THREE OF THEM.
EVERYBODY SHOULD GET A HOODIE,
IF UP TO ME.
>> HEY.
SHOUTOUT TO THE COMMENTS, MAN.
YOU GUYS MAKE THE SHOW.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO KNOW YOU MAKE
THE SHOW.
I'M ACTUALLY IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, CONNOR.
I'M GIVING AWAY MORE HOODIES.
I GOT CHRIS WALPO.
HE SENT US A HUNTER RENDITIONS
FOE.
IT'S KIND OF RANDOM BUT GUESS
WHAT.
SHOUTOUT OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THEY ARE RIDING.
I SEE -- I SEE MAXWELL IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING H GREEN 89.
HE LIKES HIS TAKE.
>> ME TOO.
>> YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT JACOB.
JACOB CZNICK 24 SAID RIDE WITH
LENNY.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT HERE,
CONNOR.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT.
MY BOY MAD DODGERS SAID EAGLES
WILL WIN TODAY.
THE COMMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLALS.
WE LOVE THE TAKES.
I'M GOING TO SAY HGREEN 89 IS A
WINNER OF THE CONTEST.
SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
SHOUT
SHOUT OUT TO YOUR TAKE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE
>>WELL, DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR FAVORITE
TIME.
THE BOLDEST BETS.
WE LIKE WHEN WE GIVE THEM OUT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE LIKE THEM
ALL THE TIME IF THEY MISS BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE A POLITLITTLE PLAYE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE FAVORITE
ONES FROM THE SLATE.
I'M LOVING THIS FIRST ONE.
YOU'VE GOT HERE GREG WITH A GUY
WE TALK ABOUTED A LOT ON THE
SHOW TODAY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF YOU
THINK THESE PROPS ARE A LOT OR
IF THEY'RE NOT.
IF WE NEED TO DROP THEM
IMMEDIATELY.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO
WHOMEVER CAN HELP US OUT.
LET'S GET TO IT.
ALL RIGHT.
THE FIRST PROP, THE FIRST PROP
HERE WE GO, CONNOR.
LEONARD FOURNETTE TO RUSH
OVER/UNDER 62.5.
400 YARDS.
TALK TO ME.
WE KNOW WHO THEY'RE FACING.
>> YEAH.
>> THE ATLANTA FALCONS.
I THINK IT WILL BE EASY.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> YOU KNOW, I USUALLY -- YOU
KNOW ME, GREG.
I DON'T LIKE RUSHING OVER PROPS
WHEN THEY GET HIGH.
INTO THE 60s OR 70s.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
I'M SORRY FALCONS, FANS.
YOU DON'T DESERVE ANY MORE PAIN
ESPECIALLY AGAINST TOM BRADY.
YOU DO NOT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY'RE
GOING TO RUN THE ROCK AND DO IT
SUCCESSFULLY.
I THINK FOURNETTE IS A SMASH
OVER 62.5.
THESE ALWAYS SCARE ME BUT THIS
ONE DOES NOT.
I THINK WE SEE THE 75 80 YARDS
AND AT LEAST ONE.
>> YEAH.
I AGREE.
I THINK HE'LL HAVE A GOOD GAME.
LOOK FOR THE BUCS TO START
RUNNING THE BALL LATER IN THE
SEASON.
PROTECT TOM BRADY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
I LIKE THIS.
I LIKE THIS A LOT TO GO OVER.
LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS.
LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
SEE IF THEY'RE ROCKING WITH US.
I HAVE JT FOR MVP SAID HE'S
GOING TO KILL ME IN FANTASY
TALKING ABOUT FOURNETTE.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
LEVINE MVP GOT FOURNETTE DANCING
AS A GIF.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
SOMEBODY SAID HE'S BEEN GOING
CRAZY.
THERE IT IS.
DANNY RODRIGUEZ SAID HE'S BEEN
GOING CRAZY.
THAT'S IT, EVERYBODY I MENTIONED
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PROP.
THE NEXT PROP.
JUSTIN HERBERT.
TWO THROW OVER OR UNDER 291
TOTAL PASSING YARDS.
IT'S A BATTLE OF THE TWO
QUARTERBACKS FROM THE 2020 DRAFT
CLASS IN THIS ONE, CONNOR.
HE THREW FOR 300 YARDS.
303 YARDS AND TWO TOUCHDOWNS
LAST WEEK.
HERBERT CURRENTLY LEADS THE NFL
IN TOTAL QBR.
CAN JUSTIN HERBERT LEAD THE
CHARGERS TO A BOUNCE BACK WIN
AFTER THEIR LOSS TO DENVER LAST
WEEK.
DO YOU LIKE THIS, CONNOR?
DO YOU LIKE THE OVER OR THE
UNDER.
DO YOU THINK JUSTIN HERBERT IS
BOUNCING BACK?
>> AT FIRST GLANCE I LOVE IT.
APP SECOND GLANCE GO OVER.
THE BENGALS HAVE NOT GOTTEN
SHREDDED BY A QUARTERBACK SINCE
MIKE WHITE CAME IN FOR THE JETS
AND THE LAST THREE GAMES THEY
HAVEN'T ALLOWED A QUARTERBACK TO
THROW FOR OVER 250 YARDS.
BUT GUESS WHAT, GREG.
ALL GOOD THINGS GOT TO COME TO
AN END.
JUSTIN HERBERT OVER 291.
HE'S GETTING 300 TODAY.
THE CHARGERS ARE UPSETTING THE
BENGALS I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT
IT.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
WHERE ARE YOU AT AT?
DO YOU THINK HERBERT BREAKS THE
STREAK OF LOOKING GREAT ON
DEFENSE LATELY, HONESTLY?
>> ABSOLUTELY I DO, CONNOR.
JUSTIN HERBERT NEEDS TO SHOW UP
TODAY.
HE HAS TO DO WELL TODAY.
TOUGH LOSS LAST WEEK.
NEEDS TO BOUNCE BACK AGAINST THE
BENGALS TEAM.
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN DO IT IS
WITH HIM.
I MEAN, WITH HIS HELP.
HE NEEDS TO SHOW UP.
HE NEEDS TO THROW.
I'M GOING OVER.
I'M BELIEVING IN JUSTIN HERBERT
TO SHOW UP TODAY AND BREAK THE
STREAK, LIKE YOU SAID.
ALL GOOD THINGS COME TO AN END.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
I HAVE JAKE VARGAS SAID HE'S
BOUNCING BACK TODAY.
LITTLE SAINT SAID HE GETS 300
AND THREE TOUCHDOWNS.
SHOUTOUT TO BOTH OF YOU GUYS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIE.
KNOWING NAYSON SAID HERBERT OVER
THAT IS A LOCK.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
>> TWO PLAYER PROPS.
TWO LOCKS IN OVERS.
A BIG DAY FOR FOURNETTE.
A BIG DAY FOR HERBERT.
LET'S KEEP IT RIDING.
WHO WILL HAVE THE BIG DAY?
IT'S BOLDEST BETS TIME.
IT'S BEEN A ROLLERCOASTER, GREG.
I LIKE WHAT YOU'VE BEEN PUTTING
OUT THERE LATELY.
LET'S GET INTO IT, MAN.
>> LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO IT.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY THAT IS
HERE TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF THEY'RE
RIDING WITH ME OR MY BOY CONNOR.
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THESE PLAYER PROPS NOT
CLICKING LATELY.
GOING TO TAKE IT A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AND LOOKING FOR DOGS.
LOOKING FOR UNDERDOG WINNERS.
I'M GOING WITH TWO.
I LIKE THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL
TEAM.
THEY'VE BEEN SNEAKY HOT LATELY.
I LIKE WHAT HEINICKE HAS GOTTEN
DONE.
I LIKE THEIR OFFENSE.
I THINK THEY CAN UPSET THE
RAIDERS ON THE ROAD.
THEN WE TALKED ABOUT IT WITH THE
CHARGERS.
THE BENGALS HAD AN EXCITING
YEAR.
YOU NAILED IT.
THE CHARGERS GOT TO WIN THIS
GAME.
THEY HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO GET
IT DONE.
THESE ARE TWO MONEY LINE BETS.
PLUS 426.
PLUS TWO UPSETS.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> I'M ABOUT TO LOCK IN RIGHT
NOW.
LOCK IN YOUR BET, BRO.
I LOVE THAT.
EARLIER YOU SAID JUSTIN
JEFFERSON SAID HE WAS GOING TO
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
PULL UP THE GRAPHICS.
THERE IT IS.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON TWO OR MORE
TOUCHDOWNS.
LOOK, HE'S FACING THE LIONS
DEFENSE.
I TOLD YOU EARLIER, I'LL TELL
YOU AGAIN, THEY ARE RANKED 29 IN
PASSING YARDS PER GAME.
RANKED 29th IN PASSING YARDS PER
GAME.
LOOK FOR JUSTIN JEFFERSON AND
THE VIKINGS RECEIVING CORPS. AND
MY GUY KIRK COUSINS.
I NEED TWO.
GO GET IT.
>> I'M ALL OVER IT, GREG.
I LOVE IT.
GREAT MATCH UP WITH THE LIONS.
NO DALVIN COOK AND AS MUCH AS WE
LOVE MADISON, WE HAVE TO GET
JUSTIN JEFFERSON INVOLVED IN THE
RED ZONE WHEN MAYBE THE RUN GAME
ISN'T AS DOMINANT.
STILL GOOD.
NOT AS DOMINANT.
PLUS 650.
HE JUST DID THIS A FEW WEEKS AGO
AGAINST A BETTER DEFENSE.
SO I AM GLAD YOU FOUND IT.
I'M SURE THE LIONS WILL MOVE BY
THE TIME I WALK OUT OF THE
STUDIO AND TRY TO GO HOME.
PLUS 650.
LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
>> YEAH.
WHAT IS EVERYONE SAYING?
I GOT JEFFERSON FOR SURE AS A
LOCK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
MATT DODGER SAID GIVE GREG A
RAISE.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> YEAH.
>> HH JOHNSON 101 SAID RIDING
WITH GREG.
APPRECIATE YOU, BROTHER.
OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
LUCAS SAID, YEAH, CONNOR, I LIKE
IT.
I LIKE IT, TOO.
XO ELLIOT SAID RIDING WITH YOU,
GREG.
APPRECIATE YOU BROTHER.
I GOT JAY DILLA -- NO LAXJAX 6
SAID CONNOR AND I ARE ON THE
SAME WAVELENGTHS.
SEVEN I MENTIONED IS WALK WAEG
WITH A HOODIE.
I LOVE CONNOR'S PARLAY.
I LOVE IT A LOT.
I LOVE JUSTIN JEFFERSON TO SCORE
TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
WHY NOT?
GET RICH.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
AND BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE
AND BEFORE YOU FILE THOSE BETS
AND THE SQUAD ROD, PLUS 110.
DO NOT FORGET IT.
STILL HAVE AN NFL JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY.
I DIDN'T FORGET.
>> CONNOR DIDN'T FORGET.
AND EVERYBODY THAT IS STILL
HERE, YOU GUYS ARE -- SOMEBODY
IS ABOUT TO BE REWARDED.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I HAVE BIG MIKE 13 RIDING WITH
CONNOR AND GOING WITH MY TEAM.
WASHINGTON WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S WORTH A
JERSEY.
IT'S WORTH A HOODIE.
I'M STILL LOOKING.
CONNOR, AH, ALL RIGHT, HERE WE
GO.
HERE WE GO.
NOAH GOLDBERG HE GAVE SUNSETS.
I'M TRYING TO KEEP IT HERE.
HE GAVE US SUNSETS.
CONNOR, THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT SUN
SETS DO TO MY HEART.
THEY KNOW WHAT THE SUNSET VIBES
DOES TO MY HEART.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, MY GUY
NOAH IS A TRUE FAN.
HE KNOWS.
HE IS WALKING AWAY WITH A JER --
JERSEY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, NOAH.
>> I LOVE IT.
OH, MAN.
WELL DONE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW TO CATCH
GREG'S ATTENTION.
THAT IS HOW YOU GET REWARDED.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
TODAY WAS A BLAST.
CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR HOODIE
AND JERSEY WINNERS.
IF YOU WON IN THE TEXT 24 HOURS,
YOU'LL HEAR FROM VR BETTING.
CHECK YOUR DMs.
THANKS TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED.
YOU MAKE THE SHOW!
THANKS TO THE LEGEND.
WE HAVE RANGER JB AND TRAMPLE
LONG TIME LEGEND.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY!
DROP YOUR REAL TIME TAKES IN THE
APP.
DROP THEM ON SOCIAL.
FOLLOW GREG ON THE VR BETTING
INSTAGRAM.
WE'LL HAVE IT POPPING ALL DAY
OVER THERE.
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY, I'M CONNOR
ROGERS.
CATCH YOU SAME TIME, SAME PLACE
NEXT WEEK!